Mary we invite you into our circle if  that's you blow out the candles oh my  god  this is a scam she deserved it mom your  job to stand at the curtains and not  attack the clients and you young lady  what's a scam feeling you are so weird  she have a lot of problems it's nothing  to concern me what's this new prop for  work spirit can you hear me yes we can  and we can see you who are you talking  to Doris daddy are you there for you did  you see her writing this no because it's  polish doors who did this  I'll show you are you here  something is happening that we can't  understand I'm concerned about your girl  the spirit world is dangerous  what are you doing not doing you're not  it feels like to be strangled to death  something is wrong with Doris  experiencing something amazing I believe  she is channelling powers we do not  understand Doris  yes  these are sharks but they can fly